hey everybody and welcome to a gaping
wild ride with steo this one is off the
charts
insane no other way to put it and we
were just being our crazy selves for
quite a while before old Scott Randolph
says uh what's going on with bam and
then the floodgates just opened and
nobody picked up a filter and it just
got even crazier so strap on your seat
bels for this one and as a side note I
want you to know that this week is the
launch of The Bucket List campaign with
the pre-order ready to go the trailer
out oh man can you not believe how
insane The Bucket List is and if you
think I I seem like I look really good
right now for those of you only
listening for those of you watching
you're thinking I look good right now
it's because this outer layer is from
Outer known and man are these clothes
epic my buddy Kelly Slater runs this
company and for my friends and my
listeners from Kelly Slater you can get
25% off your order from outerknown if
you go to outerknown.com
sto
and use the promo code steo you'd be
crazy not to do it because these clothes
are insanely epic totally sustainable
just all good practices um you know they
treat people and the environment right
and the clothes are amazing so one more
time go to outerknown.com
steo and use the promo code steo at
checkout for a full 25% off your order
now get ready cuz cuz this is about to
get
nuts people of the Universe I bring you
Brandon Novak I'm stoked to be
here boys yeah dud good to see you it's
been a minute people of the universe yep
you like saying that that's my new thing
man it's all inclusive I was asking the
the boys how many people what was the
question I asked you guys how many
people how many humanoids have there
been since the beginning of time can you
take a guess humanoid like a human I
don't know why I said humanoid to the
beginning of time so like humans not
like Neanderthal like I guess like
humans I don't know why I said humanoids
okay so there's 8 billion right now 7.8
I think I thought there was there's way
more thought there was over nine yeah
there's nine no there's not nine billion
people how many people no I think it was
7.8 I I thought it was eight I think
it's more like nine I'm steo Isaac what
are you sleeping what are you doing you
want me to Google this yeah what the
hell do you
think how many people are in the in the
world today 7.8 7.8 okay so how many
people I stand corrected how many people
have there
been I mean give me a time frame dude
probably 200,000 years well the last
200,000 years is probably when they
discovered the first human
skull how many people have there ever
been yeah what what's your guess uh
are we talking a trillion no that's what
I said that's a dumb Vinnie said I
I just Kidd I mean come on Isaac said
Isaac said 90 billion Vinnie said a
trillion um I
will land in between so like 500 billion
I'm not going to go that high I'm gonna
say in the last 200,000 years there have
been
75 oo billion what do you say ooh maybe
that's a little
high I'm like strangely turned on right
now with this conversation I don't know
why yeah it's one of those you want me
to just give it to you yeah 117 billion
people wow what did you 175 but that
would mean that
Isaac won right who's closer I was I was
under Scott was I was under when I
guessed 95 but Scott was over at a at a
closer guess I said Scott got the
closest well I was listening to a debate
and they're they're like debating this
but I was just interested anyway how are
you this conversation way out of my room
I I was I was thinking the my math
skills go as far as um I used to be
really good at 15s because I would buy
$15 bags of heroin so I can do 15 30 45
60 75 once you got to the billions and
they laughed at your trillion I'm like
dude I don't even really know what a
trillion is wait a second you
did heroin no dude no no no no no no no
no okay did somebody say heroin what was
your longest time that you spent in jail
Brandon um uh a few months over a year
few months over a year that was
consecutive yeah yeah yeah so at that
point I had made it IID graduated to the
penitentiary for sure yeah well cuz
after if you get a year more you don't
go to County you go to the yeah County
Jail is by definition for under a year
yep over a year by definition is prison
what was your longest 10 days 10 days
six six months Jesus okay so when you
went down for this Penitentiary bid you
were aware that you were going you had
to surrender yourself you knew that you
were going you didn't so I was actually
fighting the case um I I'd originally
the the the the charge stemmed from a a
prescription fraud right I I had a buddy
of mine had stole a a pad from a doctor
and he penciled out me a few perco setes
and a few being yeah I like it it was
from a dentist pad so you couldn't write
like a big script so it was like 10 or
15 because it was for like the oxycodone
30 Mig which is like a higher amount or
dosage than a dentist would normally
ever write M so had to kind of keep it
like mellow to not look
suspicious and uh I had went to the
pharmacy it was actually during the time
we were filming um number two yeah yeah
jackass number two and I was I was Ill
one day and and uh I was I had this
leather jacket on with all these
different pockets and I I was like
rumaging through my stuff hoping to find
something now when you say ill you mean
dop sick yeah yeah yeah withdrawing and
I was trying to find something to hold
me over through the day and I found this
pad this piece of paper so I went to the
the pharmacy down the street
and committed fraud yeah
totally undermine that but you wrote it
out yourself no it was already written
out oh but it didn't matter it was I I
intentionally handed it so you committed
fraud you you plad not guilty when you
knew damn well that you were guilty I
forget what my plead was but I was
fighting it and my my my lawyer
ultimately got me uh a sentence um of 11
and 1/2 months to
23 but I was going to serve 30 weekends
in 6 months house arrest is what it
equated to oh so you had ample
opportunity to put your prison pocket to
use I did and that's exactly one of the
reasons why I um ended up going to
prison so every uh every little weekend
release you load up the prison pocket
all day long which which was really just
prolonging the inevitably because when I
got sober I actually had to have
hemorrhoid surgery because my
doubled as a suitcase for so many
years yeah what's what's the most you
put up there uh I would just it wasn't
about how much it was really the way
that I put it up there like it was just
raw and rough it was like a raping
aggressive yeah very aggressive rocks
what was your process though did you
have to like make a little uh what they
call a bullet dud my process was just
quick and fast like I'd sit in the
parking lot of the jail and my buddy be
dropped me off and I'd rip off the
cigarette pack uh the the the cellophane
and I'd throw the bags in there and I'd
take a lighter and I'd light that to
make which is think about the edge like
a burnt and then just spit on it and
just shove it
up yeah like a a butthole key bump just
spit on it yeah enjoyed that a
lot yeah yeah yeah so dude one time we
were on tour with face Unstoppable
and and I was we were in Europe and and
I we happened to be in this area where
they sold a lot of smack and I didn't
have any money I'm like bam give me 100
bucks he's like no I know what you
want it for and I wouldn't leave him
alone and he's like um he's like shove
this rock up your ass I'll give you a
hundred bucks I shove the rock up my ass
a real
friend he really cared about my
wellbeing that day and uh we have all
this on footage too
actually so so I then go get the heroin
forget about the rock being up my ass
and and I wait hold on a second you
forgot the rock was up your yeah yeah
cuz I'm like komos at this point 100
bucks worth the smacks like yeah so we
do the show and uh all of a sudden you
know I would open up for face and I
would come out as uh pill Collins you
know Phil Collins the song in the air of
the night yeah I cuz I would go on tour
with those guys but I was just the
biggest because I there
was no relevance or connection with me
with the tour like I played no music I
was in no instruments I mean I'm not
going to go that far there was
absolutely a relevance and a connection
like
you're you know you're you're you're in
Bam's world and it's like uh you're
opening up the show with with craziness
the show is all about being crazy well I
wasn't in I wasn't opening it yet this
is the buildup to where I found my my
place in that tour bus because I would
just like bam was about it and I'm his
best friend so he just let me do
whatever but the rest of the guys in the
band who actually cared about playing
music couldn't stand me cuz I
just like made life hell and they had to
endure my was Jess in the band Jess
Chad uh oh wow Chad Ginsburg and Chad
actually came up with this idea they're
like Novak you have to do something
besides just be hell for us so why don't
you like open up for us and I'm like
like all right but I don't play any I
have no like you're like GG Allen so
here we go ex D you spot it you got it
get so so like all right instead of Phil
Collins You're going to be pill Collins
and and you're going to open up and
you're going to come out on stage with
like if it's a 18 and over you'll be
naked but if it's or if it's a 21 and
over you'll be naked but if it's 18 and
over you have to wear a pair of thongs a
bottle of wine cuz that's all I drank
and the sigs and and just lip song I
mean I'd sing along karaoke the in the
air of the night and just throw my wine
and smoke and just be a GG Allen
and intro the band and as the big like
would come on I'd intro bam and he'd run
out and Drop Kick Me and then the
concert would kick off did did
you get any permanent damage from being
drop kicked by bam not that I'm aware of
I know that Dave England is acutely
aware of really just had surgery on his
neck oh yeah yeah yeah I I I think
heroin helped me out in a lot of those
ways yeah I was like a Dr in a
DUI crash that's why they always
live yeah um so anyway so I I'm now
designated to be this guy who opens up
for the band and and and while I'm doing
the concert and Bam jump kicks me this
rock shoots out of my ass and I
start bleeding I start bleeding all over
the concert like for real how
big was this rock I was just like like
that and did you have to spit on it to
get it in uh I'm sure I Spit on
everything to get in my it was just like
that
came so it wasn't quite a pool
ball not not quite a q ball' be
impressive though but but absolutely a
golf ball yeah it was like it was like
that it was a golf ball you know you
know who filmed it Chris seagull he was
on that tour with us and he has the
footage so my fiance at the time was on
tour with us and you had a fiance at the
time that's why yeah she's now no longer
she when she died no no no no she had
she came to her senses and was
like dude why am I with you like so so
she is like this really good woman and
we end up they take me to the hospital
and Chris is filming the whole thing and
they have me in this room and all these
doctors come in they're making their
rounds and I'm telling did you have the
rock to show the doctors no The Rock was
long gone but I was explaining the story
and man that rock probably be worth
something
today it was worth 100 bucks that one
day to my so I'm like dude I I I
put this rock on my ass and and it's
bleeding profusely and and they're
looking at it and my ex-fiance is there
and she's like this is this is you're
you're his ex- fiance and she's like
yeah and they say could you come outside
the room for a second and they bring her
out and and they're saying he's saying
it's from a rock which has caused this
like profuse bleeding and and and
inflammatory situation this isn't from a
rock it's from years and years of damage
like you like how could you be his
fiance and he's enduring years of
damage to his alluding
to the fact that I might have been a
homosexual and then I was lying wow when
you were on tour all those years were
there ever stops where you just couldn't
find any dope or yeah that didn't scare
you from touring like that because like
when I was so strong out I just go
anywhere because I I had this fear that
I would just be dopesick everywhere I
went that's Vinnie but for me I'll tell
you I will not go anywhere without my
fume because I love it it's a diffusive
device that flavors air
and I love it what's it for it's for
ditching bad habits and I think right
now you're listening to an episode of a
podcast which inspires change positive
change to become a happier healthier you
and there's just about no better way
then to affect this positive change then
by trying fume this diffusive device is
a way to replace nasty bad habits with
positive good habits and we got a killer
deal for the listeners of the Wild Ride
podcast if it's time and you know it to
drop that filthy nasty habit that you're
embarrass of then go to
tume.to to get 10% off your journey pack
the journey pack this is the journey
that you're getting on to a happier
healthier you without that nasty bad
habit that you're so embarrassed about
that makes people have no respect for
you so let people respect you and
respect yourself by going to
trium.vira and using the promo code steo
for 10% off your journey pack and by the
way I love these so much I love this
device so much I don't go anywhere
without it and if you see me in public
ask me if it's in my pocket and if it's
not I'll do your your little Shout Out
video for your dumb buddies
because that's because that's the kind
of guy I am now go to tri.com use the
promo code steo and let's get back to
it well we're going to weigh the scales
of Justice
here it was much easier to go without
heroin in Finland than be in Baltimore
letting men blow me for 10 bucks for
sure so you know what I mean it's like H
I'll just endure it because I'll get
paid out of it and I'll just make it
happen on the next go around there's no
justice in
that we we we weighed nothing you
started off sound really I was expecting
I was going to get some like Bo nothing
crickets to my guy yeah that was
not there's no justice waight there but
that's my you know justification of so
so that was a go-to money maker and
Baltimore letting guys blow you yeah but
what about what about guys that wanted
you to blow them it it never happened it
never oh we lost eye contact when you
said
that
Justice oh Tony Rob J over here
the over here I got to believe that in
that situation it's like all right well
if if a guy blowing you is 10 bucks you
know maybe like if I'm going to if
you're going to be the blower then
that's got a you know every everything's
got a price why do heroin addicts always
like itch their nose is that a thing
like they always like I used to itch
everything it wasn't just my nose that's
how opiates aren called itchy and
scratchies yeah really yep M and and I
was never really into it it was was
annoying to me to be itching I would
take these morphine pills and and I was
just like man I don't want when would
you take these morphine pills you didn't
get addicted like that's pretty rare I
me I would uh I would take morphine
pills when I when I was giv them I I I
loved it I loved it that was just he
would get annoyed with having to itch
for more theme pills but I I can recall
vividly being locked in a hotel with him
and and like him not like really letting
us leave the room until we watch watch
footage of him and being terrified of
him seeing us out of
eyesight itching annoyed him yeah yeah
God forbid he
itches Jesus Christ and I'm the bad guy
here yeah yeah you've always been like
that huh yeah imagine imagine how bad it
was before dude I remember being okay so
walk us through uh some some prison
pocket stuff like where we're
particularly fascinated because you
might be aware about Vinnie's experience
with the prison I am I am did you see
his his reenactment on
it I did God bless you man yeah that was
that was a rough one that that
reenactment was it was a lot bigger of a
package than when I went into jail yeah
a criminally underviewed video on my
YouTube channel shocking demonstration
of how to smuggle things into prison
yeah the times are changing maybe boys I
don't know maybe it's suppressed yeah
maybe people like I don't know so here's
how so I negotiate 11 and a half to 23
30 weekends 6 months house arrest right
um while we're doing that I'm still
getting high the the suitcase
AKA my is in full effect every
Friday I load it up with drugs get in
sniff them sleep my weekend away
discharge Sunday night Monday night
religiously we have that radio show on
serious satellite yeah radio bam I
forget you know it was a room maybe two
times the size of this and it's just
like this and there's a guy working the
boards and I forget that we're going
live to the nation the majority of the
time and we'd be drinking drugging
whatever and you just forget you feel
like you're talking to your buddies and
uh I I proceeded on one of these
episodes to talk about how the um the
COS the white shirs of of George W Hill
the the the facil I was incarcerated at
the time um were worthless and how my
dead grandmother could do a better job
than them and how I was uh in particular
sneaking my drugs in on the weekend wow
so that was a Monday night I then go
back on a Friday and and they say Mr
Novak get over here when they're doing
roll call for the intake and I'm like
what so they pull me out of this line
they put me in the other line they then
put me in uh the intake Wing uh of just
the regular population of the jail and
and and I'm in the cell and I do my
drugs and Saturday I'm just thinking
it's a mixup maybe I don't know what's
wrong but there's a bang on the door and
there's one of those white shirts I was
talking about and they said come with us
and they take me into this control room
where there's a whole bunch of white
shars white shirts all sergeants in
there they're standing in a circle and
they put me like in the middle and and
there's a one who's sitting like in the
corner on a computer and he will not
look at me and you could tell he's the
boss and he starts repeating Verbatim
what I said on that radio show as the
other ones just start smacking me around
oh smacking you around did they uh did
they investigate your pocket did they uh
no no they what they did was they uh so
you had a fully loaded butthole I had
already did it at that point cuz I had
made it in but they revoked my situation
right there basically and made my next
year a living hell and that jail
actually was uh raid at one of the most
corrupt jails um because it was
privately owned at the time it's now
publicly owned
so there there was no more storage no no
that there was no more release dates for
me I I and what they would do is they
would move me to these different blocks
first they put me um in in the shoe
special housing unit where it's 23 23 in
one I'm lacking to sell 23 hours a day I
can come out 1 hour a day one day uh
three days a week um to get a shower and
they well loock you and you could only
have a a Bible if you had one no reading
materials no commentary and this is
right in the beginning so I'm I'm
detoxing from Methadone Xanax and heroin
at the same time and I'm hallucinating
I'm thinking that the the warden is
sleeping with my ex fiance I'm I'm
thinking that I'm on the prices right um
I'm feeding this imaginary pig that I
named Minon and Minon yeah and I have
this Sy and his name streets he's this
uh Muslim Jihad guy great guy
and he like caught me jerking off one
day on the top cell he's like yo you
jerking off I'm like yeah like I feel
some kind of way about that not
like any particular way but just some
kind of way like it's a little fake give
me a little bit Direction here you mad
or you happy where we going with this
Jesus and then so they put me from there
to another block and then once they
realized they couldn't do anything more
with me they revoked my time they would
then come and they' rip all the cell
blocks apart just to make the other
prisoners mad at me because any block
they put me on meant that I was hot and
they were going to disrupt the block you
know H so how long did it take you to
detox in
there in jail it's easier to detox you
know cuz you just accept the fact that
like this is it so I mean I was probably
good within like two to three
weeks then that's that's where I found
out that D had passed while I was on
that oh wow when I was doing that bid
now when you're locked up up and you're
done detoxing do you have the thought
I'm like okay I'm done with this like
I'm done with this life I I'm never
going back to that no I was done
with heroin and cocaine but I was going
to drink yeah that was my plan so it
sounds like that was
uh not while filming number two but
while filming number three that very it
was one of them yeah yeah my timeline's
a little so you didn't do any you didn't
drink or do drugs for the rest of that
bid I did cocaine once time in jail mhm
with another s of mine whose name was
Jihad he was a Muslim guy and we were it
was during the the month of Ramadan and
we were F I was fasting with him and
like doing the prayers and and cocaine
and then one day he brought a bag of
Coke in and we like sat up all night and
did Coke which is the worst thing to do
in jail it was hell like it's
like doing coke on a plane that's no fun
I had a lot of fun doing C I was going
to say me know I could see you like
loving that and just turning into a
party I remember like during takeoff
because the plane's like kind of more
loud and like you know like during
takeoff I'd be like right in my seat
right in my
seat um so yeah that was that was a good
amount of of Juicy uh War Stories We all
we we love that here have you had any
like super close like uh overdose
calls yeah yeah I mean that was
kind of like a that was my goal every
day was to
like anything but the dreaded
underdose so true for sure so so true
yeah yeah so I figured out the method to
like the the easiest and most sure way
to overdose and that was 180 milligrams
of methadone and like three bars of
Xanax Jesus dude when you say you're
detoxing from Methadone and heroin
reminds me of the time I met Bob Cat
gold and and and he says he offered me a
a a piece of Nicorette like
um you know the quit smoking gum yeah
and I was like oh man no no no I'm good
dude I don't want that like I was like
what are you quitting smoking he says no
I smoke
too yeah yeah just like he just loves it
you know I can't get enough nicotine
yeah my sponsors like that can't just
all the the chew the gum the patch and
smoke and smokes like what the
like dude I Can't Get Enough is
that is that comparable to being on
heroin and taking
methadone it well you can't really do it
together one kind of blocks out the
other right the methodone was more of
just a a safety net yeah well they give
it to you for free right if you're in
the clinic yeah yeah but I was like I
kind of knew believe it or not I knew
better than I knew that that was not the
right Avenue to take to make things
better but go get it for free just to be
on the clinic methodone in general they
call Liquid they call Liquid handcuffs
it's super my mom's been on it for like
30 years still yeah she's still on it
and it sounds like it probably works for
your mom yeah I mean she it it
definitely does work for like she hasn't
like touched a needle in 25
years but I mean she will be on it for
the rest of her life what's that
documentary about methadone it's so
gnarly methadonia Maybe methadon
that's exactly what it is oh my God is
that a gnarly documentary yeah and if if
if I'm wrong but I think the uh like the
methadone like it soaks into your bones
too so it's a lot harder to detox from
methodone I remember I remember
literally trying to knock myself out
like banging my head on the cement
because the pain was so bad and this is
why it with your psyche for for 7
days I I laid in my house and I was
withdrawing and I was feeling better and
better and better as time went on and
then on that Eighth Day I plummeted and
felt like worth you know what I mean
like right it just messed with your mind
when you think that things should get
better just like quite the contrary it
gets tenfold worse and I couldn't I
literally was banging my head on the
cement yeah it's tough so you got off
methadone yeah by force in there yeah I
really have any options Suboxone is like
a pill form of me and then what's the
other one there's a subex subex and
suade is the shot yes yeah do you
sponsor guys that are on suboxin because
if I talk to a guy and they're like well
I'm on suboxin I'm like I can't even
with you you know what I don't mess
with is gimmicky overpriced shaving
products and that's why I stick with
Harry's they're the shaving company with
the highest satisfaction in the whole
industry and that's because they've got
the highest quality German engineered
razors and they're at the most
affordable price I love Harries I've
been using them for years and I'm never
going to stop ever plus they've got a
killer deal for you man this starter kit
it's got the weighted ergonomic handle
the five blade razor the traveling shave
cover the foaming shave gel it's a $13
value for just three bucks man you get
it for three bucks and that's how cool
Harry's is plus an awesome subscription
ser
so you don't even have to think about it
you just get your products automatically
and you can cancel the subscription
anytime and keep in mind they've got the
risk-free money back guarantee that's
how awesome Harry's is I love them I'm
never going to use anything else and get
this deal by going to harry's.com
sto hurry up while you can get that
starter kit for just three bucks and the
way to do it
harry's.com
steo you're going to love it now let's
get back to it I I sponsor anybody
really really I've sponsored guys that
are like actively smoking herb but want
to quit alcohol I I personally and it's
just my opinion which doesn't really
mean much but I think that anyone can
benefit from the knowledge yeah Fair
Point and who am I to say when it will
be for it to take you know looking back
in my first Treatment Center when I went
there strictly to prove a point why
didn't belong there was a piece of
knowledge that was shared with me then
that was like forever going to impact me
later and when the time arrived where
things aligned it all made sense and it
stemmed from that one saying I can
relate to that my first time in rehab
was
1995 I was 20 and uh this counselor says
something along the lines of you know
look around like 10 there's 12 of you
only 10 are going to make it or
something like that or like 95% of
Alcoholics never achieve long-term
sobriety and I just thought like well
then you know then screw that yeah
it you know like if I was really into
the idea I got a 5% chance like forget
it and um those statistics that thing
that was said in that rehab in
1995 like kept me
loaded until the point that it kept me
sober yeah because when I finally got
like the
just the willingness when I was in that
cord after Knoxville's and the
intervention I was like man okay I'm
going to do this but I remembered those
statistics and I remember going into the
rehab and saying look I know that the
odds are not in my favor I want to give
myself every Advantage I possibly can so
however long you recommend I be here I
want to stay considerably
longer and uh it was Dr Drew who was in
charge of the rehab and he said that's
great but if you're really you know
serious he says I don't recommend you
stay here for more than 30 days but I do
recommend after 30 days here you go into
a sober living and I stayed in sober
living until I had two years of sobriety
and again it was just because dude like
I know those statistics man I want to be
in that 5% yeah I want to be you know
the perspective changed I remember when
uh when you did the Rip Ride podcast
when I was producing that one and um I
was like a year not even a year sober
still living the sober living I just
wanted to leave I was like I want to get
the out of this house and I
remember asking you I was like why did
you stay in sober living for 2 years and
what you said like struck a chord with
me you're like I want to give myself the
best chance of long-term sobriety so I
was and so when you said that it really
like made me think and I stayed for
three years so killer I don't think I've
ever heard of anybody who stayed in
sober living until they had two years of
sobriety who's not still sober today and
and uh the the crazy thing too you know
what you just said that you were like
you know antsy like got to get the hell
out of here you know those moments where
I felt like super uncomfortable and I
got to get out of here were specifically
the moments that I needed to be there
the most for sure it was 100% just the
disease just sitting on my shoulder be
like dude you got to get out of here
come on you got to get out of here I was
100% going to get loaded if I wasn't
over living at those moments yeah and so
thank God I was there and all of the
rest of the time godamn life was so
simple back then wasn't it life was so
simple man all I had to do was just get
through the day like I had just lost
like you
know half or more than half of whatever
savings I had because I got sober in
2008 you know was the financial the
financial crisis just wiped my out
like and and somehow I was not even
like I don't remember being gripped by
Financial fear I was just life was just
super simple dude I mean at that time
for you and then for me later on all
that was expected in early of sobriety
was for my only job was to stay sober
and people didn't believe I could do
that and like you know and then once I
stayed sober now like there's tons of
responsibilities and and things I want
to ask you guys' opinion on uh Matthew
Perry dying in the back yeah I mean that
54 dying in a bathtub is that kind of
like a uh I think that was that uh who's
the girl that died in the bathtub
Whitney Houston no Whitney Houston died
in a bathtub but they said that was from
cocaine and she got into a hot bathtub
and like it caused her heart to
stop Joey Diaz was saying something like
that Carter died in a bathtub so when
somebody dies in a bathtub I mean how do
you or a hot tub there's more I think
there's
more like bathtubs and hot tubs man how
do you do you know anybody that di in
hot tub that the chick from 8 Mile
Britney Murphy Britney Murphy did she
die in a bathtub I don't know I think
she was a I don't know if it was in a
bathtub but that was an overdose right
type in celebrities who have died in a
bathtub or a hot tub wonder if we ever
hear anyone dying in an ice
bath I don't think you going to hear
that no way
dude no dude like like actually people
are overdosing they're flopping around
they're about to die they get tossed in
an ice
bath their Naran
yeah the greenice of Nar so what is that
is that like you're you're you're
up like drunk and you fall asleep or
you're on pills and you pass out or I
mean here what I I I apologize for
interrupting you I'm I'm very very
mindful about that I care about the
audience I care about you're mindful
about apologizing but you still
interrupt not so bad I'm just being
funny but you're getting you didn't
interrupt me there not I'm I I'm so much
better and I really care about it with
that said with that said with that said
I think that nobody is dying drowning in
a hot tub 54 years old and they're
cleaning sober yeah yeah I mean but I
I've been shitfaced in the hot
tub and like I'm not you know like you
wake up or I mean they said already
today that they that there was no
illegal drugs on the scene but in the
house there was all kinds of and I could
I think even said there was no drugs in
his system that's we don't know that for
mon we don't know that for months until
toxicology comes back so and months
they'll probably say yeah it was like
all these prescription drugs that were
on that were on the scene now here's
something I'm glad you brought it up
yeah what a shame yeah I'm glad you
brought it up
there's something about like putting
your story out there like waving the
flag of sobriety he just had this Memoir
come out last year I remember when I did
the the the steo rise and demise or
demise and
rise and it was like I was like oh man
this is so scary because there's like a
really bad track record for celebrities
who come out like waving their flag of
sobriety and I'm all good now you know
like and uh I I was just wanted to be so
careful about that and and it me to this
day so what do you think Brandon the way
that he's like oh yeah you know like I
mean you're so front and center with it
yeah the first about his untimely death
and really unfortunate I think is it's
it's just so tragic because history has
has a way and tendency of kind of
repeating itself generally if you look
at the the the analytics of that and um
and if that's the case it's just really
sad because it didn't have to be that
way right like that's a death that could
have been completely
unavoided uh and and it just I don't
know I don't want to say that I can
predict the future for
me I just love love love drugs and
alcohol so much like insanely amounts of
love and and sick twisted like
relationship that yeah
that that and skateboarding were the two
things that consumed me 247 ate it
breathed it slept it dreamt it couldn't
get enough of both and then you know
when I got sober I kind of just carried
that mentality of like I this is just
what I do and who I am and I never
really thought much about you know the
pronouncing it to the world and
declaring this I'm this sober guy but I
used very publicly I I never I hit it
when I had to but I I never that whole
um you know um uh anonymity wasn't
really my bag personally so I'm I don't
know I I can everything that I'm saying
it could be like a complete belief and
notion of mine or it could just be me
justifying or deflecting like the fact
that maybe could be a slippery slope for
sure but I also think with like people
like you guys uh with such a big
following like your guys' story has the
potential to reach and help so many
people like a lot of people look up to
you guys so and and a i I would have to
think a lot of them have some sort of
drug addiction or mental whatever
whatever they're going through they see
guys like you you know it I think that
there are arguments on both sides for
sure like yeah you know lead by example
whatever like inspire people by by by
walking the walk
however it it gets really murky when you
are uh
P pumping your sobriety out there to
benefit um like with power pre property
and
Prestige big you know like when you know
and it just kind of felt like his Memoir
would like like the way he was promoting
it I I don't know it felt kind of felt
kind of weird well they say you know
that my history states that every time
that I was consumed with the money the
prop than Prestige I always was diverted
from the primary purpose which was to
simply just stay sober right because I
I'd become um completely sidelined with
the The Glitz and the Glamour the the
women the the places the things and
really all I was doing was just filling
this internal void with that external
solution and and there's no substance
there it always kind of yeah at your
guys' level I feel like it'd be hard to
be anonymous I mean would do you right
would yeah I mean I don't know and and
here I am being a total hypocrite
because we're talking about sobriety and
and putting it out there and you know
like it gets very very
blurry um I think that my Approach is
just
to not have that be like just my thing
you know like I remember um before I got
sober James Hetfield from Metallica he
got sober they had that some kind of
monster Metallica a document remember
that and it was like as much as it was a
documentary about them finding a new
basist recording a new album it really
was a documentary about James Hetfield's
early recovery and it showed him like
super vulnerable super afraid and like
he put that out there in the world but
he didn't start writing songs about the
12 steps you know like it was like he
put that out there in the world and then
he moved on and like was Metallica he
wasn't like hey I'm Mr 12ep guy he was
James headfield from metalico and I
really latched on to that you know like
I took that as my inspiration to put
that steo demise and rise out there it
was out there and then I just went back
to being like steo you know doing my
jackass thing you know and um by having
that kind of a balance and keeping my
Prof professional life about like my
professional life kind of separate from
you know from recovery that's why when
you reached out to me Brandon about
doing some gig and uh and it was like oh
it was all about recovery and I was like
Yo dude just because they're selling
tickets for it I just can't you know I
can't I can't and I get that makes
complete sense to me I get and but then
and then I kind of look at it sometime
from the perspective of like you know in
Rec my recovery and and the whole harm
reduction world it's like there's
there's no margin for error yet it's
impossible to do perfect and like
usually when I find myself in these
positions where I up just the
right amount it takes me back to like my
relationship with my higher power which
is where the real work comes from um you
know which is kind of where I'm at now
because um you know I opened that
facility and I mean how many sober
livings do you have now six six sober
livings and rehab yeah yeah you have an
Inpatient Rehab as well wow good for you
Redemption that's sick Redemption
treatment I love it so but so with that
right like my defects I'm a 44y old
single man that lives with three cats
and and my defects are like I'm not
great at relationships so when you were
saying to to Mr Randolph here I hear you
and I'm sorry that's my like five days a
week to all my employees like you want
to know what your defects are get into a
relationship so God's like all
right I'm going to give you like a
facility and you're going to have to
make all of your your employees happy
and you're going to have to make them
seen and and feel heard and let them
know that their opinion matters and you
know all the stuff that I'm not great at
being a single selfish man A lot of
times what about like people
who attack you like on social media and
so I've seen some some of people are
like oh Brandon maybe even uh bam was
attacking you in this way that's like
how you know but like every time Brandon
Novak puts somebody in rehab he's
getting paid by their insurance like
like you're like I don't know if you
ever called you like a Florida Shuffle
guy but but but then it's like so
profiting off putting people in uh the
rehab what it was called bions yeah yeah
yeah is who I worked with and then and
then it's like and then getting these
houses for sober living where he's got
the
he's got the the drug addict residents
who are living in the sober livings like
paying the morgage so that he can own
the houses you're a real estate Tycoon
yeah uh well what I know is that like
you know hurt people hurt people right
and so I I totally and I've been where
people like that are at right I've seen
me do the same thing so I get that um
and truth be told it's just couldn't be
farther from reality like um there
nowhere in this world does an insurance
company cut you a check for sending
someone to rehab like it just doesn't
work that way um so that's just not you
I get a finders fee no that's like
insanely illegal dude a mentor in the
program started he was the first guy to
start um we were walking and talking and
he was like yeah he's like you know when
they started doing like the $40 $50,000
month sober livings he's like I started
that and I was like oh don't you feel
bad about like you know people he's like
no why would I he's like people will pay
$40 $50,000 Staying Alive is expensive
and that's how he justified in his head
and he has the biggest rehabs in the
world and he's like he's at peace with
it sure and and even the the whole piece
about you know you get the mortgage on
the house and you've got the sober
living business paying the mortgage
bills like I mean when people go to
sober living they got to pay for for the
sober living absolutely and so if that
is going to be a mortgage as opposed to
a rent then big whoop because they're
going to pay it anyway and so if you're
smart enough to end up at the end of the
run with the houses and you own the
houses because you were able to use the
houses to help people with the sober
living then screw it you own a bunch of
houses that's right screw it as a man in
recovery Brandon Novak has no issues
with his business practices around his
sober livings and I might add as a man
in recovery myself I have no issues with
my practices using blue chw tablets it's
right man doesn't even factor into the
equation when I want to be intimate with
my lady and perform at my highest level
that's gosh dang darn right I will take
a blue chew tablet maybe even two and
I'll chew them up about a half an hour
later you can bet I am very intimate
with my lady it's how it works man and
if you want to try it which I think you
might because who doesn't want to
perform at their highest level if you do
then the good news is you can get an
entire month supply of blue tablets
absolutely for free all you pay is five
bucks for shipping
and man you go to blue.com use the promo
code steo consult with the medical
provider so everything's above board you
got your prescription in a matter of
moments and boom an entire month's
supply of Bluetooth tablets on its way
to you absolutely for free all you pay
is five bucks for shipping simple as
that just go to
blue.com and use the promo code steo now
let's get back to it so that's exactly
my play complete transparency and
authenticity right here I the six houses
that I own um they cost no more I think
the most I paid for any of them was 270
right and these are five bedroomroom
three Bs kind of old Victorian historic
houses in Wilmington Delaware I charge
each guy there's no more than 10 people
to a house um and each of those
individuals pays $180 a week rent now
are you strictly cash yes strictly cash
no one Insurance that's the cheapest
around yes um and no insurance and I
provide scholarships for the first month
for any of the client in need um because
I understand that we don't end up there
by way of Financial Freedom
right like that's quite the contrary so
although it costs me a little bit on the
front end I'm losing on the back end as
long as I give them that month to kind
of focus on their Foundation of their
recovery the sobriety and their
structure of of long-term sobriety they
end up staying there for what I suggest
is a minimum of a year because that's
what I did wasn't trying to reinvent the
wheel just redoing what worked for me I
don't have the answer here I just know
what my story looked like and um and
they stay and they become consistent
payers of rent and what happens is I've
pulled money out of those houses twice
and that was just in the beginning when
I left banion to open up Redemption um
to pay my bills cuz I no longer had this
income coming in and those clients pay
the mortgage I don't even know what's in
the accounts so that the money that it
cost for me to get the house is The
Upfront money once it's open and full
the clients pay the mortgage now if you
left treatment and you were going to
move into an apartment you need a
minimum of $10,000 to do that minimum
upfront Furniture first month last month
security deposit good credit to get
things turned on in your name generally
addicts burn those bridges and no one's
going to co-sign for them right so I for
that if somebody came to me and was like
dude I'll give you $50,000 for your
house to turn it into rehab a month I'd
be like it's a no-brainer dude 100% so
my end game there is I don't even know I
swear to God I have no idea what's in
that account now my end game is that I
can do one of three things I could sell
it as a franchise I could just own the
properties outright or I could uh let
someone else run it and and let them
just kind of do and I just stop in and
run you know run courses or
groups what does it look like for people
in these subber livings like how often
are they being drug tested so there's
each house has a house manager they're
the way they pay their rent is by living
there free and baby babysit basically
babysitting the the clients in the house
they have curfews they have to attend
five meetings a week they have to have a
sponsor they have to actively be seeking
um employment chores chores they have to
work with their sponsors on the steps um
and every Sunday night we have a a
check-in and we go around and see who's
where are you paying rent are you behind
what step are you on what's your
sponsor's name what's his number we call
them this actually November fourth we're
going to be having our our our
three-year anniversary party which is uh
it's house one uh just yeah for the
first one opened literally November 4th
three years ago now each house is AA
mandatory any any mandatory any kind
just some program yeah because you know
there's a lot of different ways to skin
a cat for um I think and for me when I
hear people say I'm Brandon I'm an
addict I'm an alcoholic it's like saying
hi I'm Brandon I'm a dog I'm a German
Shepherd it's like personally it's just
kind of one and the same um and it's
it's a beautiful thing to be able to to
go from that guy who used to shove rocks
up his ass for a hundred bucks uh and
and and just do a lot of really unkind
thing to human beings to to hopefully
leave this Legacy of of Novak's house
which just Prides itself on literally
helping any man in need as long as we
have a bed are you uh are you strictly
male or are you co co-ed male yeah co-ed
is a whole other thing and that's why I
created Redemption right it wasn't
because it was a money grab um it's a
whole different beast and as I evolve as
a person it's like now I'm in the world
of like um hiring a psych practitioner a
medical director a Clinical Director and
and I have a billing company that dealss
with the insurance companies which
they're like Mobsters in itself but
that's a whole other conversation for a
different time but I saw unfortunately
that the demand was there my houses are
full there's a waiting list I I just
didn't have more and I'm like dude I've
been around I've been sober long enough
to really believe that I can do
anything that I want I could become a
brain surgeon if I want no doubt in my
mind I'm like I can do more and be
better and help more so I created
Redemption and just it's just basically
my house on steroids how do people apply
to to get into your place the facility
yeah just call it's it's a treatment
center yeah yeah so you can call you can
go to the I'm try all up a plug for you
n I'm terrible at selling my just
talk about shoving rocks up
asses do you have any future plans for
like detoxes outpatients anything like
that yeah yeah I'll I'll expand I'll
grow um right now I'm just trying to
make sure that like my employees are
happy it's a startup I've invested every
dollar that I have my three credit cards
are maxed out at the moment um I I have
like just enough in my account to cover
my bills this month I had to give an
employee a $220,000 raise because he
took a a
$3,000 uh decrease in pay to come work
for us you know so it's just like a I'm
really learning how to take people's
feelings into consideration H it's tough
yeah it's like I had to step out on
faith like it's easy to say like I
believe in God or my higher power
because God can be a discouraging word
but like let me see you like show me how
much you believe and that's what I did
what what are some of the random ways
people do to like pass drug tests cuz
there's some things that like people do
like they pour Gatorade in there and
it's like and it passes and you know
have you seen Gade really my brother did
that like in the 90s he poured it in
there and it's like yeah he's clean and
I but it's
blue well no it's the thing though it's
like like we we piss the guys and women
but the the piss test don't even really
matter because the behaviors are going
to tell you when you're up you
know what I mean like when you're I mean
it's good to know and we for clinical
perspectives we have to document it and
they have to like really let like that's
the professional way but I Thursday dude
last week was tough man Thursday uh
three clients decided they were going to
go out and smoke crack and do heroin and
then within like a 10 hour band we had
to to isolate them we had to separate
them from the rest of the clients
because that can be like a a disease
that they kind of manifest throughout
and plutes the whole Community um two
chose to go to rehab a 19-year-old kid
just thought it was a better idea to
walk down the street and continue to
smoke crack and that's like a sad thing
because the kid has a a history of just
overdosing um so we deal with that we
process that Friday and group and then
Friday night another guy decides he's
going to go and do heroin and overdoses
and and the ambulance has to be called
and and they have to give Naran and
that's like really traumatic for people
early in sobriety and and I didn't know
that I was signing up for that yeah you
know what I mean yeah they say when you
get serber buy a suit totally because
you're going to have to go to a lot sure
yeah and unfortunately weddings
have you had any like serious tragedies
at your house um dude so okay so the one
that the anniversary that the three-year
anniversary that we'll have this uh
November 4th will be in dedication to
three of our residents that died mhm
that's the reality died in in the house
while in the house one in the house but
the other two yeah out but lived at the
house and
that's everybody carries a message you
know of you do or what not to do but for
the grace of God there go I and that you
know what initially upset me and turn me
off about the program now incentivizes
me and motivates me to be more proactive
in my deal to cure that so I'm not their
family coming funeral how many house
managers have relapsed in the house two
but now we and since then we've now have
a a general house manager whose job is
to solely oversee the house managers
because we got to a point where director
of operations yeah we were kind of like
LAX of days ago foolish on me to believe
that like because they're the house
manager they're exempt from well
especially when the highest rates of
relapse like are for people who work in
recovery MH yeah my sponsor told me that
in the beginning I'll never forget it
and I said I said what do you think
about this and he's like I think it's a
bad idea and I said why and he said cuz
the majority of people that work in
treatment relapse I said why he said
because your work is not your recovery
and your recovery is not your work and
the moment that line gets blurred MH yep
you're but I knew that and now
like ignorance is no longer Bliss I I I
I'm to be held accountable for this
information that I know what's the
craziest thing you've ever seen scoring
drugs in the streets of Baltimore dude I
one night I I got stab one night I got
stabbed in the head I one night I got
stabbed in the head I was um I was I was
it was upstairs in this abandoned house
I was running this room from this guy
named slim it's an abandoned house but
I'd pay $10 a night to sleep in this
abandoned house and it's like 4 in the
morning and I'm I'm leaving the house to
go kind of secure my finances for the
day whether it's robbing cheating
whatever I have to do but I'm getting an
early start a head start of the day here
go get her yeah right forward thinker I
am and um as I walk down the stairs it's
a really sad sight there's a uh a milk
crate on the floor and it's there's a a
piece of plywood on top of it and
there's there's this little Chinese
store we would go to cuz there's no
electricity and we would buy these
little 10-cent candles and that room was
used to get high and I came down at 400
in the morning and Slims at the table uh
this woman Ann nette and this woman
Robin and a and a baby in a carriage and
they're smoking crack and the baby's
crying and uh and Annette calls me she
said come here my other two friends who
I was with they left they were outside
come here I want to talk to you and with
that Robin who had just the woman woman
with the baby she had just got out of
treatment so she was pretty like had
some weight on
her she she yoked me up and put me in
this headlock and and uh and she's like
give me the money give me the money and
I had $10 hidden in my sock and somehow
they knew that I don't know how they
knew it but I refused to give the $10 up
the baby's crying they're smoking crack
it's 4 in the morning in this really
like terrible part of Baltimore City
baby's crying I won't give the money and
then finally she says Robin says Anette
give me the knife and I'm like I I don't
know what's happening and the net hands
Robin what I think is a knife who then
proceeds to start stabbing me in the
head finally after like the fourth
puncture I I pull the 10 bucks out and I
I give it to him and I see that she
stabbed me in the head with an ink pen
and I like made it out Jesus like oh
it's a pen give me back my
10 you d uh yeah yeah um yeah dude
so uh so so business is is good
unfortunately it is um we're growing
exponentially we've been met with really
Open Arms um and it comes back to the
fact that that I'm there every day I
love it um I run the first group every
morning at 9:00 a.m. uh my office is is
like a humongous trigger I remember I
told you I love drugs and alcohol so
much that I I commissioned this
phographer and uh we went back to
Baltimore and he shot present day photos
of the two corners where I bought all my
heroin which are still active drug shops
and I had them blown up so big that if
you sit in my office it's like a 3D
version of like Google Images you feel
like you're in the hood buying which
probably isn't a great thing um but I
just have this sick twisted you know I
showed my medical director the other day
or the psych practitioner and he's like
you you should he's like this older
African guy he said you you should be
very proud of that and I was not
expecting that from him yeah he found it
to be motivational what's the proximity
of all the six
houses I ironically enough 13 minutes
away from my facility is the first house
the first two houses which 13 is my
lucky number it's my 13th Treatment
Center I went to um the first two houses
are directly across the street from each
other the third house is right at the
top of the street the fourth house is a
half a block over the fifth house is
half a block down and then the six is
across from that and I somewhat did that
intentionally because I really wanted to
to create uh a sense of community and
accountability and for people who are
like in the sixth house to interact with
the people that are in the first and
second house which are the intake houses
to show them that like what recovery can
do because when you're in the sixth
fifth or fourth house you're established
you have a job you have a car you have a
girlfriend things that look appealing to
early
sobriety so so it's structured such that
you come through the house and you
progress down the line yes yeah yeah how
long do you uh until you move into the
second or or the third or the fourth
house it's a case by case situation um
where you at with the work with the
sponsor with your rent are you actively
participating in your sobriety do you
have a do you have a home group do you
have a do you have a commitment you know
a lot of things go into account but what
I've learned and thank God this is a
real privileged problem to have we don't
have a lot of guys that come there and
end up relapsing we have a lot of guys
that come there and just think that it's
a little too structured for their liking
I remember I remember checking into to
Sil Living For The First Time and
hearing about the curfews and the chores
and this and I remember thinking man I'm
being treated like a child know like
this is regular man they don't know like
d like a who I am yeah yeah and uh God
I'm so glad that I that I just that they
oh yeah like I should be treated like a
child because left to my own devices
it's all bad for sure little did they
know they little did you know they
really knew who you were right it's like
they don't know who I am we
know you better than you know you I
remember to like uh living in the sober
living I had a house Slip like I'd have
to go to meetings and they were like if
you've got like a a house slip a nud to
court card something that you've got to
like document that you at the meeting
then you put it in the basket you come
and I remember it like it was real hits
my ego at times to put my house slip in
the basket because I thought that I
thought everybody's looking at me
everybody's just hyperfocused on me
they're going to see me put my house
slip in the basket and it's going to
tell them that I'm here because I have
to be here because I'm but I'm not like
I'm I'm in stubber living because it's
my choice so why do I have to house Slip
and uh just so glad that I swallowed my
pride every time that that was uh a
concern and I just did it you little do
you know they're probably just like God
damn it here's another slip which means
I'm going to be later to meet this girl
that I have a date with like they could
give a less why you're there what
house you're in or what your plan is
right oh 100% have you uh have you heard
from
bam I have not and the reason why is
because um I had to to create some
healthy
boundaries right um in the last cuz he
just celebrated 60 days yeah um there
got to a point at the end where you know
when we were talking and I don't think
he was in a good he wasn't in a good
place then he was like really spewing
this hateful stuff and I'm like this
this behavior isn't acceptable to me
like I I I accept where he is as a human
being but I don't need to show up for
that to take that okay for the record
did you crash his car absolutely you did
100% okay
oh is is is he going off about the car
no no I just remember back in the day
and I just never heard you address that
but I was wondering I was like uh
absolutely did um and he he easily what
he says is true he could have reported
the car stolen to the insurance company
and got reimbursed he did not I didn't
go to jail he ate that cost um but
without me having to make this like a
it I mean I'll just say it um on
the 28th of every month Phil receives a
check from me from Financial amounts
which has been actively happening now
I'd say for the past two years or maybe
three good for you so but that's not
something that I needed to you know we
can cut that out if you want to cut it
out I was just trying to be funny and it
turned into the serious thing it's
totally cool um and I really don't care
either way but I'd see people say that
and they'd come and I took a note and
lesson from you which I do a lot um
where I really
stopped buying into social media I
stopped reading the comments I stopped
letting cuz I saw you do that yeah dude
I I did my best to avoid the comments
man so now I'm at the point where I'm
trying to practice like one hour a day
social
media like Vinnie now you got me got me
worried like what no dude all good
you you really sold that
yeah um so uh so what bam reaches out to
you and you don't pick up the phone or
no I I had to block him oh wow um just
because at the time when I did that he
was like really not exhibiting nice
behaviors this is recently right he had
a fairly recent rant on on Novak B like
four months ago is sound about right um
but what I do believe is true now is
that he is probably doing the best that
I've seen him do in a long time and the
reason why is his skating I can tell
when he's like not just like standing on
a board get a shot of me I saw that like
that uh it was it wasn't a melon it was
but it was
over you know it's like alcoholics like
you whatever you say doesn't matter
right but like your behaviors will tell
me exactly how you're living his
skateboarding I can tell when he's like
thoroughly sincerely skating and he only
does that when he's doing better the
last time I saw him do that was when he
was filming the vice thing in Spain with
Winkle that was he's he's back there
again so he looks good you know he looks
good on his social media here's the
crazy thing is that uh two days ago my
buddy Darby Allen who the wrestler for
aew and he's just a rad skater A rad guy
the guy who went down the halfpipe in a
body bag yeah yeah the the the vert wall
quarterback at Baker um he's yeah I I
love that guy and he's like pretty tight
with bam came he came over and he's
skating the ramp a couple days ago and I
was like hey man I lost touch with bam
you know like I I don't have a number
for him I don't anything you know but
like but I want bam to see my ramp dude
can you like just text him this clip
that I just uh shot of you skating just
text it to Bam and uh Darby let me know
that bam got back to him and he said uh
he bam asked was steo talking about
me and D Derby said no he wasn't he just
wants you to escap his ramp something
like that and uh I'm I'm glad man I got
I'm not I'm not here to talk I mean
right now so ironically enough his
girlfriend this girlfriend that he has
who seems to be in inciting some kind of
motivation in him uh messaged me the
other day she me and she said this is
like 3 days ago and she's like um I just
want you to know I've never met you it's
nice to meet you I don't know what your
past looks like but um bam is like you
know he he misses you and he talks about
you often and and he smiles when
conversations come up about you you know
and and that's nice yeah I don't I don't
think that I will like um want
to reenter entertain like a I'll no who
the am I to say that I'll show up
for him whenever like he did for me um
and hopefully it will take somewhere
along the line yeah the craziest part
why I brought up Darby Allen is that he
told me Bam's got his alcohol monitor
bracelet off I was shocked he's got it
off and he isn't exactly I I that's
crazy I would have bet my I even said I
bet my sobriety when that bracelet comes
off he's right back to where he left off
and when I found that out I was just I
was like wow things are changing maybe
right and and I I would say thank God
for this this court case thank God for
this criminal court case because I think
bam is legitimately terrified of getting
wasted and ending up in jail because of
it I've seen a lot of handcuffs create
sobriety for people Big Time divinely
inconvenient
yeah it's all it's all also like you
know family judge well it's like when
the family stops enabling that's when
you usually get sober you know or when
like your closest friends so of course
like a a lawsuit from Jess like you I
mean it's a tough decision to make if
you're Jess but you have to do that kind
of sometimes not a lawsuit criminal
charges what's the difference one is uh
well yeah what is the difference I mean
the Criminal Courts deal with with
freedom and civil courts deal with uh
money
H like well regardless because I
remember I was telling the story like
when I heard on L line Dr Drew and he
was like dude like if you have a family
member that's a drunk and he keeps
driving call the cops on him get him
arrested have him go to jail that's
where I'm at and a lot of people are
like I would never do that to my
it's like right bro I mean at the you
know 20 30th time like that guy
even if he's my brother like he's going
to hurt somebody and you can't just sit
there and watch whatever the case may be
you know and um I I I had a call with a
with a lady the other day I her I used
to work with her son and and um son
wasn't responding to the text and so I
texted his mom and I was like hey have
you heard from so and so and she's like
oh he's in another rehab and I you know
she was just venting and venting and I
said you ever thought about doing alanon
they do not want to hear about
alanon and it's like uh it's just a
strange thing like like they can't they
have this rationalization in their head
that you know I would never do that to
my son or I'd never like it's my baby I
don't want to it's like but you baby
them you bury them yeah absolutely I'm a
big fan of things getting bad right CU
for me things had to get really bad
before they got really good and I I
adopted that mentality from my sponsor
my first sponsor I was at the end and I
was in a bad way and I was stranded at
the airport and I like was really
contemplating suicide I had come up with
a plan and I I texted uh my sponsor and
I said dude I'm going to like kill
myself this is I can't do it and his
response was a picture of a poppy plant
you know it's like and he always said to
me you never get between an alcoholic
and their bottom ever ever ever ever and
and that for me my experience states
that I had to have repercussions for my
actions like and without that like
unmanageability for me is a Monday
morning cup of tea the pain has to be
unfuck bearable yeah unbearable how were
you going to do it kill yourself oh un
alive yourself I had um I well when I
had got
sober I had this bag and it possessed my
belongings and and in that bag I was
also an accessories wh but I had eight
scarves I liked scarves I would tie off
with them I would use them as belts um
but this day I was going to go into the
men's stall of the BWI airport where I
was stranded and and kind of like this
make this makeshift noose on which
surely would have fail but in
the in the bathroom stall the very last
one where businessmen hang their jackets
while they like I was going to hang
myself there you would have fell yeah
yeah it wouldn't have worked I'm like
frail I'm sick I couldn't tie a proper
authentic knot hold my weight yeah dude
but that was it I was
done for sure well I think that uh as it
relates to Bam neither of us are mad at
him and that's the thing it suckss been
skating a lot lately and uh I I skate
and then I'm like dude I'd love to skate
with him he's a fun guy to skate with
and I and I believe and I hope that
we'll get some sessions in at some point
I just wish that there wasn't a wedge
between him and his family that's What
Hurts the Most you know like I can
handle him like you know losing contact
with me but it's like man with the all
the you know me it's that's your Mom
that's your dad that's your brother like
come on dude you know like with the that
that that upsets me but when he guys
when he talks about you guys you
know it's not real right like are or do
you like get your feelings hurt
sometimes I'm I'm gonna um reveal
something here there was a uh I'm very
good friends with this radio DJ the
radio host in Tampa Mike CTA Mike CTA
hit me up he said hey
I've got bam coming into the studio
tomorrow are you guys cool and I was
like I don't even know if we're cool I'd
love it if you asked
bam so Mike CTA asks bam on the radio
are you cool with steo bam says I love
steo but I went on tour with him and and
he's supposed to pay me a bunch of money
to go on tour and then he put all the
money he owes me into a trust fund for
Phoenix and I want to know why I did the
work I get the money why are you getting
trying to give it to Phoenix who can't
even get it until he's 18 and and like
this upset me because that's calling me
a liar and a thief and and it's simply
not the case there's one thing you are
not and that is not a liar yeah number
one there is no trust fund for Phoenix
because bam has refused to sign up on
one being created they just doesn't
exist so so how I would have put money
into a trust fund for Phoenix is uh
there's no way number two I absolutely
paid bam specifically on January 31st
because I asked Scott to look it up and
uh and he got every oh wow every damn
penny that was promised to him 100% he
was supposed to go somewhere else during
that time and you paid that guy yeah
what double what he was Ed or whatever
that was yeah what like everything that
was agreed to I honored my word and then
two months after the fact then I I
reached out and I said hey we've got
these boards you know we've got like
some of these boards left over trying to
figure out what to do with them and I
said I'll tell you this is two months
later I said I'll tell you with what's
remaining of these skateboards I'm happy
to sell them and I'll even sell
unlimited
more but at this Point given all what's
happened like I'm only going to sell
these boards if your half goes into a
trust fund for Phoenix this was in
relation to transactions that had not
happened that moving forward in the
future and that marked specifically the
moment when I lost contact with bam he
was so outraged I got a drunken call he
was so outraged and I've I've never
spoken to him since um but he had the
date he had it Mex mixed up he he
changed his number like he he like uh I
just I've had no communication with him
but I was so I was so upset that um by
um I was so upset by what he said
mischaracterizing the what happened on
that Mike Cal show I turned around and
bought a cameo video from him that's
amazing we play the clip here we were
making
this we were making this came video
which is so such a amazing such a
classic video but uh do we have it did
he respond yeah we have it we could play
it from here oh that's so good and uh
and it just said hey uh steo says that
uh you accused him of not paying you and
uh in fact he uh well you you hello dear
Rando fan it's bam marer here and you
know what my parents handle my bills and
I haven't spoke to them since they took
the other side in the courtroom so I
don't really know what's going on but
last time I checked when I I guess I was
pretty bad on alcohol they said that
steo was setting up a trust fund for
Phoenix to get paid when he was 18 and I
was like but I did the tour so why
doesn't he pay me long story short
apparently everything worked out fine
but they sent the money to my parents
which I don't talk to so everything is
just great and I love steo rock and
roll for the small fee of $50 bam too
will agree with
you yeah you can do that I'm doing it
dude I didn't so good I didn't expect
him to actually uh respond but but but
what what we wrote Into the request was
hey steo says that you accused him of
not paying you but in fact he did on
January 31st and that he never even
brought up a trust fund for Phoenix
until months
later scroll
up okay dude enough with that yeah oh so
he did that and then he went back and
well no I didn't expect him to
to okay hey Bam steo said he's bummed
you accused him of not paying for going
on tour with them he says you got paid
everything you were owed on exactly
January 31st uh for both the shows and
the boards you guys sold and that he has
he has the documentation he said he
didn't even bring up the trust fund
until two months later and that was only
about selling additional boards after
that point he thinks you're out there
calling him a liar and a thief can you
make a video message to
steo that I can post and and tag him it
hurts my heart that he's so upset I mean
what the who needs the court of law
when you have
Cameo I I didn't expect him to make the
video how fast did he respond uh days we
we put a 24hour on it oh you pay a few
extra bucks yeah yeah yeah and and the
24 hours elapsed I figured he was never
going to respond to it but I didn't care
I just wanted to like I wanted to know
that he got that information
accusing me of something that I didn't
when I sent that to you I think your
response was like wow you know like you
were impressed with you know his when he
was on tour with us did you see any
glimmer of hope because like he was
hitting meetings with us every night we
were reading out of the big book you
know like he was sober the I'm pretty
sure he was sober the whole time we were
on the road he was sober the whole time
on the road but what I what what's a
Telltale sign for me is when somebody
blames other people people for their
problems yeah and I unfortunately heard
a lot of that but uh I mean I had a
great time with them yeah but that kind
of goes back to the notion that I said
earlier you know something that was a
seed that was planted unbeknownst to me
at that first attempt to treatment where
I went there strictly to prove a point
why I wasn't you sober weird
people and I didn't need what you do to
have this good life ultimately ended up
being like one of the main Foundation
stones in my recovery when the timing
aligned
right and that's my answer to the
question is that I didn't see any
glimmers of Hope but I felt strongly
that we were planting seeds that might
later uh turn into something well he's
probably going to see this do you guys
have anything to say to him or is that I
mean we we we said our thing man like I
I don't want I don't want anybody out
there like accusing me of something I
didn't do I cleared that up um and you
miss them and I'm rooting for him like
position is always going to be hey it's
always been the same yeah if you can
just get all all we've ever wanted was
him for him to be happy healthy
prosperous have a good life yeah yeah
end of the story and and everybody's got
a different approach to how you want to
help somebody be happy and healthy and
prosperous some people think that
enabling is the way to to get that some
people think tough love is the way to
get that you know like like who
you know none of us really know we all I
think I hope we all want the same
outcome I think everybody yeah everybody
absolutely wants even even the haters
yeah even the haters on his Reddit in
their sick weird way they want a good
outcome too yeah they just it's like
we're we're all sick in our own way and
my sickness is shown in different ways
than Vinnie's or Scots or your you know
what I mean yeah so not
mine there's no feelings you know so bam
come skate the new ramp yeah come skate
the ramp man you know the only thing is
I want happy healthy prosperous I want
him to have a relationship with his
family you know and uh and and and
that's that yeah I support whatever it
takes for him to to be happy and and
have that reason to get out of bed every
morning for like the lust of life like I
support it yep were you guys going to go
skate yeah dude let's do it man I gotta
I got to go uh we have a double date
with my friend Lisa Vanderpump oh I just
went to her restaurant the other night
oh yeah cool TomTom was really good
where you where you going um we're going
over to our house oh wow my plan is to
bring uh my laptop computer and
for and
reaction I'm actually really surprised
you didn't do it with
Brandon show him your special he he came
and saw the show on tour yeah yeah yeah
okay amazing yeah yeah yeah yeah the the
the the the first time I knew that was
real that Steve showed his footage I
remember we were in some Hotel it was a
nightmare it was 3 I'm
scarred man no no it was 3:00 or 4
in the morning and he was uh he was
editing this YouTube video and and uh he
made a a cut to it for like a 3 second
change and he woke me up out of a dead
of sleep he's like dude check this out
we watched the whole video I'm like
what' you do he's like hey no I changed
that I'm like dude you woke me up for
like
a imagine not sober
dude yeah dude all right Shameless plug
though man if anyone needs help they can
reach out to me and my team directly 610
314 6747 Redemption addiction treatment
center will we say that again cuz I
rudely interrupted yeah 610 314 6747
call me directly uh if you're looking
for help or interested in learning more
about my new treatment center Redemption
how much is a sponsorship uh $180 a week
so times 4 is 720 I do 15s we've already
established this I you my heroin ratio
is 15 so I did it last time you and Ste
I'll sponsor one more one more month for
somebody I was so bummed you guys your
show got cancelled but I was going to
bring all the guys from the houses and
you were going to I had the two guys
that you both sponsored who are still
there and sober who were going to come
and and like we're so stoked still sober
I would love to FaceTime you at some
point with them let me do one more month
for somebody that'd be amazing we can
connect me with your girl yeah yeah
that'd be really rad I love you boys
thank you for the platform thank you for
the
time and there you have it dude you uh
included the all the The Cameo stuff did
you put in the actual video yeah it's
nuts it's nuts that that episode was
nuts and uh hey man if you're still here
you know that you are special to me and
did you hear me mention in the very
beginning that the bucket list is going
live we got the trailer out there we got
the pre-sale going you're going to get a
better deal oh you know what let me tell
you it's the same deal except if you use
the promo code what is the promo code I
think I'm making it up right
now promo
code huh yeah dude
street team oh I wonder if we can give
the street team an even better
dealy let's do I want I want to have
multiple promo codes promo code street
team I'm gonna see if I can give the
street team more money
off yeah and it's only going to work for
the first 48 hours so you got to be like
on it quick all right street team promo
code street team on the checkout of the
buck this special oh it's so good I love
you
guys